que phileas ex chargé de communication
et ex-responsable syndical sud aérien
est présente sur ce plateau
bonsoir merci de répondre à nos
questions un million 27 1945 signature
pour le moment alors où je vous parle je
suis donc sur la page internet du rip
pour contester donc la privatisation adp
la date limite on a dit approche à
grands pas il y avait neuf mois il reste
plus que 35 jours donc du coup les 4
millions 700 mille soutien ne ne seront
pas atteints c'est une déception alors
ce n'est pas surprenant pour plusieurs
raisons au niveau du shit et de l'outil
pour lequel on pouvait donc participé il
ya eu énormément de bugs
ça c'est le premier problème en plus
c'est un outil informatique donc sur le
web tout le monde et pas forcément
compétent pour pouvoir y participer
il ya eu une grande mobilisation
ceci dit je vais être honnête avec vous
je pense que les 1 millions ne font pas
peur à monsieur mâcon il devait s'y
attendre de toute façon ce qui est
dommage c'est que c'était l'opportunité
pour effectivement la france entière de
pouvoir s'exprimer
c'est le premier donc la première
opportunité qu'on avait de ce type là et
c'est un peu dommage qu'on n'y soit pas
arrivé je pense que l'outil n'était pas
parfait pour pouvoir arriver à ce
chiffre aussi rapidement
et effectivement je pense que monsieur
mac on s'y attendait de toutes les
manières
vous dites que l'outil n'étais pas
performant vous dénoncez des bugs
informatiques qui a que ça qui explique
qu'on n'arrive pas à 4 millions 700
mille signatures qu'est ce qu'il aurait
fallu du coup s'il n'avait pas eu de
sites internet
alors il pouvait y avoir d'autres outils
d'autres supports certainement je crois
que la deuxième problématique c'est ya
eu des supports papier certainement
peut-être né saurait pas ralenti le
processus d'aidé mises à disposition
des endroits publics ce genre de choses
parce qu'il ya eu en fait des des
personnes qui se sont investies mais de
façon individuelle si vous voulez sur
les marchés il ya des gens qui ont
installé des espèces de spots où on
pouvait signer me citer des démarches
individuelles c'était pas des démarches
du gouvernement et c'était pas selon
leur volonté je pense qu est la deuxième
problématique qu'il ya eu sur ce sujet
c'est une déficience et un déficit de
communication extraordinaire de la part
des médias dirais-je grand public
notamment les journaux télévisés les
grandes chaînes comme tf1 ou france 2
etc etc
de mémoire je n'ai pas souvent entendu
parler de cette opportunité de cette
possibilité de se manifester
je crois que la troisième problématique
c'est que nombre de gens n'ont pas
compris ce qu'était aéroports de paris
justement en quoi la privatisation
vous inquiète alors adp et déjà
privatisés adp est déjà une entreprise
privée en fait le terme privatisation et
pas adéquat
adp est déjà une entreprise privée par
contre la problématique c'est si le
gouvernement se désengage de ses plus de
50% d'actions
il ya deux problématiques d'abord il va
vendre un bien qui avant était un bien
public
on parle de bijoux de famille souvent en
quelque sorte la deuxième problématique
c'est qu'on ne sait pas combien il va en
vendre et à qui et si il y avait une
urgence pourquoi m la possibilité de
mettre en place un référendum
donc il y avait il urgence s'il n'y
avait pas d'urgence c'est un choix
politique peut-être ou stratégique de la
part de monsieur mâcon qui a besoin
d'argent effectivement et qui sait
peut-être dit aussi si c'est pas moi
qu'ils le fassent ce sera le prochain
gouvernement
justement le rip référendum d'initiative
partagée c'était un rêve un gouvernement
précédent c'était sous le quinquennat de
nicolas sarkozy qu'il a été mis en place
donc on a dix 10 % du corps électoral
pour atteindre 4,7 millions de
signatures à la fin du grand débat
l'année dernière emmanuel macron a dit
qu'il était prêt à abaisser ce seuil
autour d'un million là on a déjà dépassé
le million le rappelle un million 27
1945 soutient ce que du coup pour être
présenté ce rythme aux français bien
justement la question n monsieur macron
avait dit que peut-être la question est
ce que monsieur mac on tient ou doit
tenir ses engagements est ce que c'était
une promesse définitive ou pas le mignon
est atteint c'est sûr c'est pour moi
c'est déjà une victoire extraordinaire
est temps de les circonstances et le peu
de facilité qu'il y a eu à les obtenir
donc pour moi c'est un bon chiffre
maintenant est ce que monsieur macron va
s'intéresser à ce million qui s'est
manifestée avec difficulté ou est-ce
qu'il va l'ignorer
pour être honnête avec vous ici monsieur
maquereau ou son gouvernement ont besoin
d'argent je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils
s'intéressent à ce résultat là de toute
façon les dernières questions très
rapidement il ne reste plus beaucoup de
temps
si ce référendum était réellement soumis
aux français ce que vous pensez que les
français prendrait position contre la
privatisation de dp alors s'il y avait
une véritable explication sur la valeur
de l'entreprise
le danger effectivement à ne plus
maîtriser une entreprise qui est la
porte d'entrée de la france donc les
aéroports de paris et qui représente des
milliards
je pense qu'effectivement surtout pour
ne pas savoir ce que ça va devenir
je pense qu'effectivement les français
se seraient peut-être un peu plus
intéressé à ce sujet ces mots de la fin
merci dominique philias d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes ancien chargé de communication et
ancien responsable syndical sud aérien